the long simmering tensions between the
United States and North Korea South
Korea's Air Force released details of
its joint aerial operation with the U.S
this week that included live fire drills
that came hours after the North's claim
that it had tested a nuclear-capable
underwater drone as military tensions
ratchet up once again there are some in
South Korea who are trying to win a war
of information with the North Elizabeth
Palmer met some of them on a recent
visit to the two countries border
just visible in the distance behind
heavily guarded borders North Korea has
long been isolated but never this
completely ever since the beginning of
covid when North Korea really sealed its
borders it's been virtually impossible
for anyone to get in or out but that's
not true for something else something
some people would call propaganda and
others information
in free North Korea radio's tiny studio
in Seoul Kim Sung Min broadcasts
shortwave messages into the north
including today greetings from U.S
politicians the point is to let North
Koreans know that there are American
lawmakers who wish them well
Kim's organization also fills bottles
with rice USB sticks containing news and
a US dollar bill for Smugglers to take
North but it's getting harder thanks to
a Crackdown by North Korea's dictator
Kim Jong-un
Andrei lankoff is director of the career
risk group borderves China used to be
quite open very poorly controlled a
paradise for smuggling not anymore then
he began to establish control over
computers
media pictures appeared to show perfect
loyalty to Kim Jong-un but this dictator
doesn't trust his people North Koreans
may have computers but no internet and
what they're allowed to see is closely
monitored Kim has also recently
increased the penalties for trafficking
in foreign content if you produce it or
sell it's really risky you can end up in
the concentration cabinet there
that hasn't stopped jungwang ill he's a
Defector now in South Korea and works
with flash drives for Freedom filling
donated USB sticks with everything from
human rights law to Hollywood movies
it's not going to be easy to smuggle
these across the border but he will find
a way so what's on this one for example
these are views of Seattle to counter
North Korea's official depiction of
America as the evil empire oh that's a
very well stocked food store the fact is
even Kim Jong-un Can't Stop North
Koreans hungry not only for food but for
information from getting it as long as
activists like these are determined to
feed the demand
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Elizabeth
Palmer in Seoul South Korea